aus achern ist uns der bundessprecher
der afg zugeschaltet guten tag herr
beutel
haben heute die ukraine hat viele sorgen
in bezug auf russland
der konflikt in der ost ukraine die gas
pipeline nor zudem zwei wenn sie gestern
in kiew gewesen wären was hätten sie
präsident selensky mitgegeben
ja ich glaube das ist dass es wichtig
ist der der ukraine eine klare
perspektive wird zu geben und zu sagen
dass zum beispiel die sorgen die sich um
nord stream zweitens die eu keine angst
empfunden unbegründet sind wir müssen
freilich als als deutsche zunächst
unsere deutschen interessen vertreten
und ich sag das deutlich habe es immer
gesagt noch sind zwei liegt im deutschen
interesse
wir haben eine sehr fragile
energieversorgung durch die verkaufs der
energiewende wir brauchen stabile
energieversorgung der stream 2 ist eine
weitere leitung die in unserem interesse
lincoln ich glaube nicht dass die eu
keine sich der große sorgen machen muss
ich wohl keiner hat aber angst dass zum
beispiel der konflikt wieder aufflammen
könnte sobald diese pipeline eben durch
die ostsee geht und russisches gas nicht
mehr über die ukraine transportiert wird
die ukraine sorgt sich auch über den
wegfall von milliarden die durch diesen
russischen gastransit weg sein können
also ganz unbegründet sind die sorgen
der ukraine doch nicht ja es gibt es
geht dazu vorerst um geld das ist ja
auch legitim
sind übrigens nicht etliche milliarden
sondern es sind meine es ist 13 bis 500
millionen die der ukraine da wegfallen
aber diese gasleitung die durch die
ukraine geht für die eu keine eben auch
geld bekommt das ist in über zeit
sowieso stark zurückgegangen das wird
weiter zurückgehen aber es ist völlig
klar dass die verträge dann bis 2024
bestehen und alle seiten auch die
russische seite haben sich einverstanden
erklärt dass das selbstverständlich
eingehalten wird und dann muss man 2024
0 sehen und sollte sich deutschland also
dann dafür einsetzen dass diese verträge
verlängert werden über 2024 hinaus und
sollte es kompensationszahlungen geben
von deutschland an die ukraine für den
wegfall der gelder durch den gas
transfer
na ja da habe ich zweifel wissen sie das
sind marktwirtschaftliche verträge und
wenn wenn da ein vertrag ausgelaufen ist
dann kann man darüber sprechen auch mal
ein folgevertrag macht ob das sinnvoll
erscheint das kann ich mir übrigens
durchaus vorstellen weil das auch eine
weitere option ist für die
bundesrepublik deutschland eine eine
zuverlässige energieversorgung
sicherzustellen
aber zusagen für den fall dass man da
aus steigt weil es gar nicht mehr
gebraucht den kompensationszahlungen zu
machen speziell dafür würde ich für
falsch halten das heißt nun nicht dass
man die ukraine nicht auf andere art und
weise in ihrem reformprozess unterstützt
das sollten wir tun das ist auch in
unserem interesse
eigentlich die beste lösung wenn die
ukraine ihre transitleistungen umstellen
würde und stadt russischem erdgas grünen
wasserstoff transportieren würde und
vielleicht sogar europa damit helfen
könnte die klimaziele noch zu erreichen
das ist zukunftsmusik das ist eine
vorstellung die ja im raum steht ich
halte das für nur für eine option die
man auf jeden fall weiter verfolgen
sollte ob das dann tatsächlich der
energieträger der zukunft wird das
wissen sie das wissen wir alle noch
nicht genau das ist im wesentlichen der
sache der ingenieure
aber es ist eine option und diese option
nicht preiszugeben hatte ich auf jeden
fall für richtig ja dann lassen sie uns
noch kurz über den konflikt in der ost
ukraine sprechen die eine aktion der
krim sollte sich deutschland ihrer
meinung nach weiterhin einsetzen für
formate zum beispiel dass man die format
um eine vermittlerrolle im
friedensprozess oder in der deeskalation
dort zu übernehmen naja man kann das tun
und es geht hier darum den
gesprächsfaden nicht abreißen zu lassen
dagegen spricht im grunde genommen
nichts aber zur ehrlichkeit auch zu
sagen deshalb ist jetzt völlig erfolglos
also das geht jetzt wird das minsker
abkommen von 2014 und
damals auch übrigens mit dem
französischen staatspräsidenten urlaub
dass das erfolglos verlief wird auch
frau merkel nicht ernsthaft bestreiten
das hat bis jetzt nichts gemacht das
heißt nicht dass man deswegen nicht
versuchen sollte immer wieder auch
diplomatischen wege diesen konflikt
beizulegen
ständig schwelt und der
doch innerhalb europas stattfindet
insofern halte ich so richtig zu
sprechen ich bin aber auf gestand nicht
sehr optimistisch dass das nochmal die
formate wirklich etwas erreichen will
lassen sie uns noch einmal auf das
deutsch russische verhältnis schauen der
spitzenkandidat der afg und ihr co
bundessprecher group aller der kann ja
vielen russischen positionen etwas
abgewinnen die viele als unrecht
bezeichnen würden also zum beispiel
russland verbietet deutsche nicht
organisation
nichtregierungsorganisationen für
menschenrechte da sagt herr krupp aller
da gibt es sicherlich gründe dafür
cyberangriffe sagt er verglichen
russland die vergiftung und lagerhaft
von navalny sagt herr kuba wollen die
seit keine opposition teilen sie diese
russlandfreundlichen positionen
nein ich habe dazu eine sehr
differenzierte position ich hatte
zunächst einmal daran für richtig dass
wir ein interesse haben müssen
gutnachbarschaftlichen beziehungen zu
russland und ich halte auch die
sanktionen für falsch die wir da haben
weil sie nichts bringen und weil die die
beziehung dauerhaft belasten die
bundesregierung hat hier versagt am ende
der der ära merkel steht ein hochgradig
belastet das verhältnis zu russland das
sollten wir korrigieren ich habe
allerdings etwas zurückhaltender
position als europa hat zu einigen
einzelthemen das klären wir aber etwas
machen will schade dass wir uns diese
position nicht noch verteidiger noch
erzählen aber danke am heuten für das
gespräch ja